In mathematics, when an expression gets complicated, we can add parenthesis
to show structure or grouping--(x - 3) x 5 is different than x - (3 x 5).
Python regular expressions have similar parenthesis,
but they're written a litttle differently.
The closing parenthesis looks just the same,
but the opening parenthesis--the version you'll be using in this class--is 3 characters--
(?: ).
There's a simple example.
This regular expression makes a group around xyz and then this whole thing
can be repeated 1 or more times,
so some strings are xyz, xyzxyz, and so on.
Suppose we want to find words made up of combinations of musical notes.
In Western music, the notes are often given names--do, re, mi, fa, so, la, ti--
and you could put them together in various combinations--re, fa, fa--do, do, re--
stuff like that.
Let's say we want to recognize words that are made up of these syllables in order,
or these syllables not in order but in any combination.
So we set out to try it.
We can have a bunch of do's or a bunch of re's or a bunch of mi's.
Let's say we're looking for all of the matching strings in mimi, rere, midore, doo-wop,
and we want to see which ones we get.
We'd like to get mimi as 1, rere as another, midore, and then maybe do,
just sort of as a corner case,
but mostly these 3,
but we will be unpleasantly surprised.
We would really expect something like mi+ to get mimi.
Maximum munch rule, why have you betrayed us?
If you look over here, you'll see that actually everyone of these little musical syllables--
'mi', 'mi', 're', 're', 'mi', 'do', 're'--seem to come out separately.
Why? Well, if you think about it, in the regular expression 'mi+",
the plus only effects the "i", so really this is getting mi, mii, miii--
an entire virtue of selfishness--rather than the thing that we wanted.
You can actually see this over here at the end where do+ got us doo from doo-wop.
So here, the + isn't applying to the right thing, isn't binding correctly.
This isn't quite the right way to do it.
This, however, is.
Note our use of the parenthesis in regular expressions--
(?:--marks the beginning of such a group--),
and then here in the middle we have do/re/mi.
Anything inside this group can be repeated 1 or more times.
This gets us just the answer we were looking for.
For a more thorough investigation of musical notes and the associated words,
I recommend The Sound of Music,
but it's also worth pointing out that a very popular computer musical format or interface
M-I-D-I--MIDI, the musical instrument digital interface used for recording
things like pianos or synthesizers or drum sets, is more or less exactly what we've seen here.
Basically, a list of notes and modifiers and combinations over and over again.
By contrast, formats like MP3 or other audio compression approaches for recording voice,
do not follow this general pattern, or at least they don't look like they do at first blush.